2017 has already produced a ton of
Hollywood hits like Disney's live-action
version of Beauty and the Beast
DC's long-awaited solo pick for Wonder
Woman and Jordan peels sensational
breakout thriller to get out and it
looks like the silver screen surprises
for this year aren't done just yet
whether you're into action comedy horror
or drama there are plenty of forthcoming
films that'll be fighting for your movie
ticket money over the next several
months
it's the 1990 TV mini-series adaptation
of Stephen King's it amassed a cult
following but unfortunately the for our
features laughable special effects and
disorienting cutaways haven't aged well
Tim Curry's original performance as the
town terrorizing clown penny wise still
set a high bar for anyone to follow in
the role though so when the new version
of the character played by Bill
skarsgård was first revealed in a
costume that could have easily been
borrowed from a schoolgirls dress-up
chest it's only natural that the movie
faced a little blowback but everything
we've seen of it since then has been
absolutely bone-chilling and gives King
fans reasons to believe the new
iteration will be floating atop the box
office when this movie lands on
September 8th Kingsman the Golden Circle
the creative team behind 2015's Kingsman
the Secret Service reunites for the
sequel which features the British spy
team partnering up with their American
equivalents after their headquarters are
destroyed by a lethal foe American
original cast members like Tehran
Edgerton and Colin Firth are joined by
an eclectic ensemble that includes
Channing Tatum Halle Berry Julianne
Moore and Jeff Bridges for another round
of zany action the Golden Circle hits
theaters on September 22nd 'mother
director Darren Aronofsky has danced
with darkness in his films before but
with mother he's going all-in on the
horror genre at last the film features
Jennifer Lawrence and Javier Bardem as a
couple who seems sublime until a bunch
of unexpected houseguests turn up in all
hell breaks loose while the surreal
trailer doesn't give much away we do
know it'll feature bleeding walls and
mobs with torches and lawrence screaming
her heart out and with Aronoff ski
behind the lens it's bound to be creepy
and emotionally disorienting September
15th can't get here soon enough
the lego ninjago movie yes the lego
ninjago movie is a feature-length toy
commercial but its predecessors have
managed to be
pretty swell so we can probably expect
some of the same animated awesomeness in
this one - in the movie Dave Franco's
character Lloyd sets off to stop his
supervillain father Garmadon and teams
up with fellow ninjas in a master
martial artist voiced by none other than
Jackie Chan himself I mean my mom is
weird and collect seashells your dad
level cities and attacks innocent people
so they've all got that quarks you know
so get ready for another trip to
Legoland this September 29th
american-made it's been a few decades
since we last saw Tom Cruise take the
yolk of an airplane but before he
becomes maverick again for Top Gun -
this time he's hitting the air as a
board commercial pilot who becomes one
of the world's most notorious drug
smugglers from the looks of it when
you're working with the CIA the DEA and
Pablo Escobar's drug cartel all at once
there's a pretty good chance things will
go sideways count on this one to take
flight on September 29th Flatliners if
Flatliners sounds familiar there's good
reason this upcoming sci-fi thriller is
actually a sequel to a 1990 Kiefer
Sutherland vehicle of the same name like
the original Flatliners features a group
of five medical students who undergo
near-death experiences in an effort to
document what happens in the afterlife
when they return they have brand new
abilities and insights and might be
going a little bit crazy the new
Flatliners comes across as more of a
traditional horror film than its
predecessor but if it's half as eerie as
it looks it should make the already
dense September 29th release date slate
even more competitive Blade Runner 2049
following up a towering sci-fi classic
like Blade Runner is a daunting task to
say the least but Blade Runner 2049
director Denis Villeneuve has a few big
things going for him for one Ridley
Scott serves as producer on the project
and Harrison Ford reprises his role as
Rick Deckard Ford's also joined by an
ensemble rounded out by Ryan Gosling
Robin Wright Jared Leto and Dave
Bautista what do you want I want to ask
you some questions whether the end
result can measure up to the original
remains to be seen but if they can pull
it off Blade Runner 2049 could make one
hell of a movie experience come October
6 the mountain between us it's only a
matter of time before idris elba takes
his rightful place as one of Hollywood's
top stars in the mountain between us
might be
just the vehicle he needs in the film he
stars opposite Kate Winslet in a
landscape set amid hundreds of miles of
a barren snowy wilderness in the two
must team up to escape after surviving a
plane crash it might sound a little
formulaic but we can probably count on
these two powerhouses to deliver some
chilling performances when this pic
crashes into theaters on October 6th the
foreigner this Jackie Chan driven action
flick features the kung fu legend
alongside Pierce Brosnan reuniting with
Goldeneye director Martin Campbell the
pic features Chan as the father of a
young woman who's killed in a terrorist
attack launching him into revenge mode
in the process he runs afoul of
Brosnan's character a British government
official who has ties to the IRA and who
might hold the key to uncovering the
attackers identities between Chan's
killer training and Brosnan's debonair
style the foreigner should make for one
exhilarating game of cat-and-mouse when
it hits theatres October 13th happy
death day it isn't Friday the 13th in
America if there isn't a schlocky horror
film in theatres and this year it's
happy death day
it's basically Groundhog's Day meets
scream as the film features a college
student who has to relive the day of her
death over and over again until she
figures out who's killing her if nothing
else it looks to be good for a few fun
jump scares and creative death scenes
the Snowman if campy horror isn't your
preferred brand of thrills the snowman
might be what you're looking for instead
the film follows a couple of detectives
trying to track down a serial killer who
leaves I see little clues to toy with
his investigators in a sleepy Swedish
snowscape with an all-star cast that
includes Michael Fassbender Chloe
Sevigny and JK Simmons we can expect the
snowman to be absolutely bone-chilling
once it hits theaters on October 20th
professor Marston and the wonder women
if you haven't had enough Wonder Woman
yet this year give this origin story a
try
professor Marston will give cinematic
life to the real-life man responsible
for Diana Prince William Moulton Marston
and if you don't already know anything
about the author let's just say he had
some interesting views on male-female
relationships the person is most happy
when they are submissive to a love
thirty you'll learn all about it if you
check out this pic on October 27 jigsaw
lionsgate was definitely playing a game
by presenting 2010 saw 3d the final
chapter is the very last round of
jigsaws punishing plans in the newest
round of torture trials a copycat killer
appears to be reviving John Kramer's
work in ways that are a little too
on-the-nose for the investigators
tailing this new villain just like the
other pictures that preceded it jigsaw
looks to be chock-full of psychological
and physical Horrors that will test your
tolerance for gore when this thing hits
theaters on October 27 suburbicon George
Clooney and the Coen brothers have
already proven themselves to be an
interesting filmmaking match thanks to
oh brother where art thou and Hail
Caesar and now the three have teamed up
again with the Cohens writing and
Clooney directing to bring this quirky
crime thriller to theaters next
suburbicon stars Matt Damon as a man who
loses his wife in a shocking home
invasion incident and watches as his
idyllic little town turns into a haven
for deceit in darkness as with any
Clooney Cohen collaboration this grim
landscape will be peppered with plenty
of comedy making it a must-see on
October 27th thor ragnarok in Norse
mythology Ragnarok is an apocalyptic
series of events that results in the
world being plunged into water after the
deaths of several gods including Odin
Thor and Loki and culminates in a
planetary rebirth so it's obvious from
the title that this chapter won't be a
jolly good time for our hammer wielding
hero no idea the good news is his
imminent participation in the upcoming
Avengers infinity war means they'll
probably emerge from this adventure
relatively unscathed but before that
he'll have to break out of prison
without his hammer and play gladiator
opposite none other than the Incredible
Hulk so we can definitely count on this
to be a marvelous new adventure for our
Avenger friends when it busts into
theaters on November 3rd supply
this would be such fun daddy's home -
the first daddy's home didn't exactly
thrill critics but audiences ate it up
so in true sequel fashion daddy's home -
is doubling down on everything that made
the first movie stand out including
twice as many dads as the original this
time around returning stars Will Ferrell
and Mark Wahlberg are joined by John
Lithgow and Mel Gibson as their
respective fathers naturally chaos
ensues once this quartet gets together
so prepare for some major dad jokes when
this family comedy hits theaters on
November 10th Justice League as DC's
biggest boldest attempt at a shared
universe outing Justice League will pull
together its all-star Super Hero Squad
of Wonder Woman Batman Aquaman the flash
and cyborg as they tangle with the
latest villains to threaten the earth if
the massive receipts on Wonder Woman are
any indication of member 17th will be a
big day for the DC extended universe
when this superhero smash pic lands in
theaters they said the age of heroes who
never come again
costume Coco as Pixar's first non sequel
since the good dinosaur Coco tells the
story of a young boy named Miguel whose
family has banned music his love of
instruments leads into the land of the
dead where he teams up with the
trickster named Hector to unravel his
family's history across both planes of
existence count on this Pixar pick to
make a splash when it boughs into
cinemas on November 22nd the disaster
artist Tommy Wiseau's the room is known
for being the single worst movie ever
made and James Franco's the disaster
artist aims to humorously explore how
such a terrible picture ever made it to
production in the first place unlike its
source material the disaster artist is
actually expected to be good and will be
a must-see for any movie fan when it
lands on December 8th the shape of water
Guillermo del Toro has got away with
movie monsters and the shape of water
looks to be an especially beastly treat
the film stars Sally Hawkins Michael
Shannon and Octavia Spencer as it
follows a disabled janitor making pals
with a water creature that's tucked away
in a secret research tank with all the
eerie atmosphere and authority of Del
Toro's distinct I behind this film
consider your calendar space for
December 8th already booked Ferdinand in
this animated pic John Cena stars as the
pacifist animated ball Ferdinand who
must escape captivity to live his life
of
and merriment away from all the rodeos
the film is based on the classic
children's book by Monroe leaf and
Robert Lawson Ferdinand will be a family
favorite when it drops just in time for
holiday break from school on December
15th
Jumanji welcome to the jungle welcome to
the jungle is expected to recapture the
magic of the 1995 adventure film Jumanji
but this time it features the rock
alongside Jack Black Karen Gillan and
Kevin Hart as the players avatars and
instead of rolling dice the characters
will be playing a video game that sucks
its heroes into a fictional jungle
they'll have to fight their way to the
exit if they want to win or at least
live damn as a man right there don't cry
don't cry don't cry it's gonna be ok
pitch perfect 3 if you thought the first
two pitch perfect movies were awesome
you're in for a treat as the Bellas
redeem for another round of melodious
shenanigans
this time the Barden ladies will be
performing at a USO show where they'll
compete with bands using real
instruments for the first time so
prepare your pipes to sing right along
with your favorites when pitch perfect 3
harmonizes with the holidays on its
December 22nd release Star Wars Episode
8 the last Jedi after the success of the
force awakens the new generation of Star
Wars is coming back with Daisy Ridley
John boyega and Oscar Isaac all
returning to the big screen in this new
chapter but what we don't know is what
will happen to the rest of the originals
especially in the wake of Carrie
Fisher's tragic and unexpected death in
2016 the title of this installment seems
to mean that Luke Skywalker is the last
of his kind as the resistance squares
off against the first order Snoke and
kylo Ren count on the box office force
to be with episode 8 when it hits
theaters on December 15th thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]